and make your way to the facilities  before it's too late  take a right  they are between the battle that last  night this is your coworker Brent you  can either talk to him and piss yourself  or you can ignore him and renew your  mission  a veteran  hurry it's almost too late  take a look you're almost there  hurry it's almost too late  crisis averted  wash your hands for immunity  now back to your feet before Yoko f is  respect your defecation  now back to you see before you a hobo  French your coworker wants a high five  you can either get in the high five and  he will think you've urinated on your  hands or you can ignore crisis averted  now back to your seat before your  coworkers expect new identity  it's the home stretch almost there  quick-step  mission accomplished now back to work